FEMALE SPEAKER: Please
welcome to the stage author
Glen Weldon.
GLEN WELDON: Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you very
much for having me.
I am delighted to be here
and to talk nerd stuff.
The book is about
the intersection
of Batman and nerd culture.
I'm using Batman as a lens
to look at nerd culture
because I think they
have a certain resonance.
Batman is the ultimate
nerd, at least
that's the point of the book.
And there are several
different Batmen
over the course of many years.
And to insist as the culture now
does that the only Batman that
is real is the grim,
gritty, bad-ass version
is to ignore lots of history.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
We can cough up the nerd
culture stuff in the Q&A,
but today because this
is a visual medium
and comics are a
visual medium, I
want to go over a
little bit of history.
May 1939 is when it all began
with this issue of "Detective
Comics".
Now up to this time--
this is issue number 27--
"Detective Comics"
was an anthology
series with 11 different
short features in it
with two-fisted detectives
with names like Speed Saunders
and Slam Bradley
and Buck Marshall.
And they introduced
Batman in number 27
because their walking
papers, their marching orders
were to make another Superman.
Superman had come
out the year before
and had been hugely
popular not just
selling millions and millions
of comics-- which he did--
but also as a
merchandising beast,
the first real merchandising
beast associated with comics.
So two guys, Bob Kane and Bill
Finger, co-created Batman.
If you ask Bob Cain, Bob Cain
will say that he created Batman
by himself.
And he went on record
many, many times saying
that it was all his idea.
In his autobiography
toward the end of his life
he gave a little bit
of hint, a little bit
of love toward Bill Finger.
But it was really
too little, too late
because he had made his career
on saying it was all his idea.
Bob Kane was the artist.
Bill Finger was the writer.
Bob Kane went to Bill Finger
with an idea for a character
called the Batman.
It was a dude in a red
long johns, basically,
with giant bat wings--
mechanical bat wings--
blonde hair, a domino
mask, and he showed it
to Bill Finger who-- they kind
of bounced ideas off each other
all the time.
And Bill Finger said
you're calling it Batman.
And he's got this-- this is
red underwear man, what do you,
what do you, what do you mean?
This doesn't-- so he went
to a dictionary and he kind
of opened it to a picture of
a bat and said look, ears.
Look, if he's going to be
a creature of the night
he's going to need dark colors.
If he's going to be
somebody who is a vigilante
he's going to want
gloves so that he
doesn't leave fingerprints.
Basically everything
that we think of today
when we think of Batman
came from Bill Finger not
necessarily Bob Kane.
So this is the first
image that anybody saw.
This image-- I don't want
to keep dinging Bob Kane--
but he traced that image
from a Flash Gordon comic.
And you can see
that there is still
some vestige of the mechanical
bat-wing idea, but yeah.
This is the title page of
the first story of Batman.
Actually you can see
he's not Batman yet.
He is "The Bat-Man".
So back then when
he was introduced
he had a definite
article, he had a hyphen,
and he had scare quotes.
He also had, if you
look at that image
there-- it doesn't necessarily
strike terror into your hearts,
does it?
It looks a little goofy.
But the important thing is
you see the black silhouette
against the full moon.
That image, that--
icon-ography, iconography
is going to be a part of this
character for his entire life.
The Batman-- a mysterious
and adventurous
figure fighting
for righteousness
and apprehending the
wrongdoers-- that's
where a hyphen should be, right
there between wrong and doer--
in his lone battle against
the evil forces of society.
His identity remains
unknown, that's important.
When this story started
we met Bruce Wayne
as a bored socialite who was a
friend of Commissioner Gordon.
We didn't find out that Bruce
Wayne was Batman until the very
last panel of this story.
But the first time we
see Batman is this.
"As the two men leer over
their conquest they do not
notice a third menacing
figure standing behind them,
it is The Bat-man!"
Exclamation point to the
Batman, three exclamation points
in case you missed it.
So again that dude down
there with the-- holding
the paper-- Bob
Kane traced that.
And these two goons have
just pilfered an old man's
safe and killed him.
And so this is Batman standing--
you can see it again--
standing in front of the
moon-- part of the iconography.
And he looks like Batman
to our modern eyes
if you allow for nearly
77 years of shift.
So the color scheme checks out.
Again, back then, it
was blue with black
because if you just did black
without any kind of highlights
in it, it would just come
off as a big black smudge.
Because that was the
printing process back then.
The one thing that's odd
to me, well, two things.
A, those ears are kind
of like devil's horns
kind of poking out of
either side of his head,
and the purple evening gloves.
Those are a thing.
The purple evening gloves
go away pretty quickly.
And whenever DC Comics
reprints this first issue
they kind of do away with it.
But it's a look.
Speaking of a look,
check out of that cape.
Now the cape is it an important
part of this character
and always will be.
For about 30 years after this
the cape is just an accessory.
In the '70s, artists like
Marshal Rogers and other folks
really make the
cape a living thing.
And they use it to
direct the reader's eye.
It becomes almost like
a silent narrator.
Here, it looks like dude is
basically wearing an umbrella.
But that's-- that's the guy.
Now the important thing
to know is that he
was a ripoff of The Shadow.
That's not a
controversial assertion.
Both Bill Finger and Bob Kane
said, yeah, we kind of just
ripped off The Shadow.
The first story was a rip off
of a Shadow story, almost plot
point for plot point.
So both Bill Finger
and Bob Kane swiped.
It was a thing people did.
Because remember that
they're not making art here.
They are churning out content.
They are churning out as much
as they can as fast as they can.
Which is-- I give Bob Kane a
lot of guff for tracing as much
as he did-- he did a
lot-- it's-- he was stuck.
And he was doing what he can.
But Batman was not the
only Shadow rip-off.
Kind of running through comics
and pulp magazines of the time,
there were a hell
of a lot of them.
He was not even the only
bat-themed Shadow ripoff.
There were two
others, Black Bat,
who's that dude there
with the fedora,
and The Bat in "Black
Book Detective".
They didn't hang around long
although The Black Bat actually
lasts until about the '50s.
But, yeah, so the same
shtick, right-- terrifying
your enemies, lurking
in the shadows,
and in The Shadow's case
and in Batman's case,
killing folk a lot.
But I'll come back
to that in a second.
This is the origin.
Now he didn't have an origin
until about seven issues in.
Because, again, when
Superman was created
he was a science
fiction character.
You needed to explain why he
could jump and do all the stuff
he could do.
This guy was basically just
a detective who dressed up,
so you didn't necessarily
need a back-story for him.
But they gave him
one eventually.
Now those three panels
down there, you see,
are the origin which we
have seen in 2016 a lot.
We've seen it far too many
times, over and over again.
By the way, the guy in the
corner there with a red cap--
traced.
The guy up there in the
yellow hat-- traced.
The guy who's shooting
the gun-- traced.
This whole thing takes
place, this whole origin--
because, again, they
had the real story
to get to-- takes
place in two pages.
Page one, page
two, and that's it.
That Batman down
there in the corner
that is traced from a Tarzan--
very famous-- Tarzan image.
That Bruce Wayne-- traced.
Now I like the way this
page looks especially
with that very astonishing feat
of the dude in speedos raising
the weight up.
That just kind of
anchors your eye.
I like him right
there as a dude who
is a scientist and a really
incredibly buff weight lifter.
You can also tell just from
visually looking at this page,
to the right of that image
with the weight lifter,
he's pretty good
at interior design.
One thing I want to put here
in the bottom left here.
OK this is a very famous quote,
perhaps the most famous quote
of this character,
"Criminals are
a superstitious, cowardly lot.
So my disguise must be
able to strike terror
into their hearts."
OK, keep that in mind.
In this panel he is calling
criminals superstitious.
In the very next
panel he says, "A bat.
It's an omen."
Pick a lane, you
know what I mean?
So again, but again
you can see the bat
against the full
thing of the moon.
Now the most important
thing on this page
is not the bat flying in.
It's not the criminals who are
superstitious, cowardly lot.
It's not how great
he looks in tights.
It's this panel.
Now we've seen this origin
told and retold and retold.
And we will see it forever.
But we always skip this panel.
And for me, this is what
makes Batman, Batman.
Not what happened to him
but his reaction to it.
"And I swear by the
spirits of my parents
to avenge their deaths by
spending the rest of my life
warring on all criminals."
That's key.
It is not a vendetta.
He's not going after the
guy who shot his parents.
He's going against criminals.
It's not a vendetta,
it's a crusade.
And I use that word advisedly,
because it's a loaded word,
but it's bigger
than the thing that
started him down this path.
And if you forget that you are
focusing on the wrong thing.
Now we will never see this today
because it's hokey as hell.
And it's a thing
a child would do.
It's a silly kind
of oath, right?
But that is its power.
These characters work,
if they work at all,
at a psychological,
elemental level.
And they work because they
key into something here.
Now just look at this.
So he's got the
candle flame and then
it's kind of echoed by the
single tear dripping down
his cheek.
There's an elemental
power to this.
And this panel is what
makes Batman a hero.
It's what transformed
him from a vigilante
into somebody who is, in
an act of self-rescue,
this is how he overcomes
what happened to his parents.
He is dedicating himself to
this notion of never again.
What happened to me will
not happen to anybody else
because I'm not going to let it.
There's a simple power in that.
And to forget it is to
focus on this stuff.
In his first year Batman
killed 24 dudes, two vampires,
a brace of werewolves-- what
would you call it, a pack?
What's the collective noun
for werewolves, pack--
and a couple giant mutants.
Here you can see
him toting a gun.
And in this panel it's kind
of tough to see but it's just
as well because there are
some horrible, racist imagery
in this panel, he is
pushing a jade statue
on top of what looks like nine
hapless dudes crushing them
completely.
And then just to put
a fine point on it,
the idol of the Green
Dragon kills its own.
Well, you kind of
helped, you know.
It didn't do it itself.
You're kind of-- you've got to
put some-- you're in the mix.
Now this violence
terrified the publisher
because he was a
children's character.
You could pretend to yourself
that all these other detectives
had an appeal because, again,
adults read comics back then as
well.
But this character
was intended for kids.
And this dark
violence was something
that the publisher-- that
made the publisher very leery.
Now it would be 10, 15 years
before an anti-comics crusade
happened nationally-- and we'll
talk about that in a sec--
but they just-- there
was a thin unease
coming from the
publisher, especially
after a panel in
Batman number one--
because he got his own
self-titled comic eventually--
where he is flying the
bat plane and gunning down
people with a machine gun.
They're like, you know what?
Maybe back off
that a little bit.
So they want to do--
so the publisher wanted
to lighten the tone.
Bill Finger, the writer,
thought, you know,
I created this guy
who is basically--
if you believe all this
fetishist bat stuff--
he's a detective.
He's basically Sherlock Holmes.
And this is the era
before thought balloons
and before narration
like internal monologue.
So if we wanted to
get access to what
was going on inside
Batman's head,
he needed to talk to himself.
Which was odd, so they
said, you know what?
Let's give him somebody
to bounce off of.
It was Bob Kane's idea to make
the person that he bounced off
of a kid.
Because he figured this
is being written for kids.
We put a kid in it they can
identify with the character,
and that's how we got to
the sensational character
find of 1940, Robin
the boy wonder.
Now even in the
marketing-- like, look at
that-- we're shoving this
guy down your throat.
Like you're going
to love this kid,
whether you want to
or not because he's
the sensational
character find of 1940.
So "The Batman, that amazing,
weird figure of night at last
takes under his protecting
mantle an ally it
his relentless
fight against crime.
Introducing is this issue an
exciting new figure" blah,
blah, blah.
Look at that.
That is just promo copy.
Now this made Batman from a
dark, lone figure of the night
into-- look at his face--
look how proud he is.
He's like, that's my boy.
It's like, it's like he's a
Little League dad, you know.
The guy's just sliding home.
That's hugely important.
Now does anybody see-- we've
all heard the jokes, right,
the Batman and Robin jokes,
the ambiguously gay duo
jokes-- does anybody
see anything here
that might, I don't know,
presage trouble to come?
Is there anything in this copy
here that stands out at you?
I'm going to take a closer look.
Anything here you might
want to be wary of?
Let's go a little bit closer.
"Takes under his
protecting mantle anally"
Now that's me, right?
Look at the space between
mantle and an ally.
Mantle-- look at that
big old space there.
Look at the space between
the N and the A, nothing.
I'm not saying it's intentional.
I'm saying, dude
couldn't catch a break,
that all these jokes were fated
to be because, well, I mean,
why?
Because of panels
like this-- two dudes
in a boat at night in a
park because it's night,
because it's soft
breezes and moonlight.
Now this is just, now I'm just
making the stuff up, right?
I'm just pulling
panels out of context
and you can make
everything look bad
if you pull panels
out of context, right?
And I just want to point out
here that for a 10-year-old boy
Dick Grayson is jacked.
Look at that, that is a deltoid.
And this very famous panel which
you might have seen before.
So basically the joke is, and
it's not a joke, this was done.
So the villain
says, "Not only you
do but so is everyone
you have touched",
because he's given him a
plague-- not important.
"Jean Loring, I've signed
her death warrant".
That's his girlfriend.
"I gave Iris West
the kiss of death".
That's his girlfriend. "Carol
Ferris in deadly danger".
That's his girlfriend. "Robin--
what have I done to you?"
Now again, none of
this is intentional.
But people noticed, one
person in particular.
This is Dr. Fredric
Wertham, M.D.
He is a German-born
psychiatrist who
in the 1940s-- late
1940s and early 1950s--
waged a one-man crusade
against the comic book
because it was fostering
juvenile delinquency.
He had a lot of different
complaints about how comic
books affected
things like literacy.
He said that breaking
up sentences into word
balloons like that
made it harder
for kids to learn to read.
He didn't spend too much
of his time directly
attacking Batman
and Robin because he
had bigger fish to fry.
There were crime comics
and horror comics
and he would pull panels out of
context like I have just done.
And he would point out the
very racist stereotypes,
the very sexist stereotypes,
and the incredible violence,
about which, dude had a point.
I mean he actually
chased hundreds
of people out of
the comics industry
and caused horror comics and
crime comics to basically,
just gutted them and caused
a lot of publishing houses
to close.
But when it came to the crime
and the horror comics, I mean,
dude kind of had a point.
Now he also said
that Superman was
a Nazi which must have come as a
surprise to his Jewish creators
and publishers and
writers, but fine.
He said that Wonder Woman had
a touch of something sapphic
to her, which, dude had a point.
And finally, when it
came to Batman and Robin,
I'm going to read what he
said about Batman and Robin.
He only devoted four
pages to this book,
four pages to Batman
and Robin in this book
that he published in 1954.
And what he said about them was
not, well, here's what he said.
I'm going to use a fakey German
accent because I want to.
And b, because I did do the
audio book for this book.
And I did double
check just to make
sure he still had the accent.
He never lost his
thick German accent.
He was born in Germany.
So this is what he said
about Batman and Robin.
[FAKE GERMAN ACCENT] At home
they lead an idyllic life.
They are both vain
on Dick Grayson.
Bruce Wayne is described
as a socialite.
And the official relationship
is that Dick is Bruce's ward.
They live in sumptuous
quarters with beautiful flowers
in large vases and
have a butler, Alfred.
Bruce is sometimes shown
in a dressing gown.
As they sit by the fireplace
the young boy sometimes
worries about his partner.
It is like a wish dream of two
homosexuals living together.
[REGULAR VOICE] Now,
dude had a point,
not the point that
he thought he did.
He went on to say that
in a culture like America
where homosexuality
was the great taboo--
and remember this
is the 50s-- this
is the height of the Red Scare.
This is when the Bolsheviks
were coming for your children
to turn them into pantywaists.
Like there was a lot of fear
going around at this time.
And he just fed
directly into that.
What he said was, seeing
all those beautiful flowers
in large vases and seeing
these two males together
would incite in
young boys-- and he
was talking to boys
at this point--
young boys reading it the
sense that they might be gay.
Now dude had a point,
but it was one that only
applied to gay kids like me.
Because, again, the feelings
of guilt, shame-- check, check,
check, check, check-- but
it's not-- you would not--
if you were straight kid and
you saw two guys hanging out
in a house you wouldn't-- it
would not even occur to you.
If you were a gay kid and you
saw two guys hanging around
in a house and you saw a panel
like this, for example, yeah,
you might think there's
something there.
Now this panel appeared
in a comic book
that was published in the
spring of 1954 exactly
as Dr. Fredric Wertham was
testifying before Congress.
So the universe kind of handed
him this panel on a plate.
Because, again, it
says, "And it begins
like any other routine morning
in the lives of millionaire
Bruce Wayne and his ward".
So this thing, sharing
a bed, is routine.
And they have a good sleep.
"C'mon, Dick-- a cold shower.
A big breakfast!"
So what happens next?
Well, as I say, a lot
of crime comics go away.
A lot of horror comics go away.
Super heroes change.
The most famous double act
in comics, Batman and Robin,
becomes an ensemble.
Because having these two
dudes hang out in the house
together even with their butler
was just a little too close
to the line.
So we introduce, first
comes Ace the Bat-Hound.
It's a dog in a mask, sure.
Then comes in that upper
right corner, Bat-Mite
a inter-dimensional
magical imp who
wears a costume like Batman.
Then comes Batwoman
and then comes
Bat-girl-- with a hyphen--
not the same Batgirl
that comes later.
And then finally, and most
awesomely, Mogo the Bat-Ape.
For about 15 years
this is-- he becomes
kind of the patriarch
of this family of people
who dress up like bats.
This is Batman in 1965.
Whack, smiling, he's got
a little-- they changed up
his wardrobe a little bit.
They gave him a circle
around his bat insignia
which he didn't have before.
This is 1965.
This is 1970-- bit
of a difference.
Cartoon, photorealism, and I
say photo realism advisedly
because look at that,
this is Neil Adams art.
The moon is in front of you
and yet the shadow of Batman
is falling forward.
So again-- ism, photorealism.
And it's my favorite
part of this whole thing
is he standing over the graves
of Delores and Juan Muerto--
Dolores and Juan Death.
Honey, the Deaths
are coming over.
Oh, I hate when the
Deaths come over.
So this is "The Secret
of the Waiting Graves".
What happened between
1965 and 1970?
Anybody know?
This dude happened.
This show premiered in 1966.
What they did when they made
this television series was they
realized that they could
take advantage of the pop art
movement that was
cresting at the time.
Pop art valued things
that were colorful,
that were mass produced,
that were cheesy,
and that were disposable.
Comics-- pop art, the pop art
movement fetishized comics.
Roy Lichtenstein made a career
out of taking comic art panels
and selling them for
thousands of dollars
into art galleries
and art museums.
So they could take the existing
comic, the Batman comic,
and just not adapt it, not turn
it into an adventure serial
like they would something
else, but just pick it up,
cut and paste it onto
the television screen,
fit it into a half
an hour format.
The difference is
they would assert
every cheesy, silly,
kid-friendly aspect,
every trope that
is in these 1964
comics with a tremendous
sense of gravity.
The way the producers
described it to the writers,
as if we were dropping
the bomb on Hiroshima.
This is how heavy, this is
how serious we want everybody
to take it.
There is no winking
to the camera.
There's no mugging.
It is all delivered as
straight as possible.
And it became, because
of that disconnect
it's because of that--
because kids loved it,
because again, pow-zap--
and it was colorful
and it looked great.
And adults loved it because
it was funny as hell.
The people who didn't
love it were the nerds.
They were there in 1966,
writing into fanzines,
going nuts about this show.
I found several
people just completely
outraged by the
notion of this show
and how it was making
fun of their character.
In fact it wasn't making fun,
as I point out in the book.
This was-- if you want somebody
to take Batman seriously,
this show takes
Batman seriously--
the Batman of those 1964 comics.
But man they hated it.
So when the show was over--
and this fad faded quickly.
Within two years they
had three seasons,
something like
128 episodes which
is why it lived on in
syndication forever.
The makers of Batman comics,
and all DC Comics basically,
said they looked
around, they found out
that their kid audience
was pretty much gone.
Who were reading comics now
were those nerds, the teens
and adults.
And teens and adults wanted
something a little bit meatier.
They wanted
something-- they wanted
heroes, like Marvel
heroes, who had troubles,
who couldn't pay the rent,
whose Aunt May was dying,
who were angst-ridden, who
had feelings of inadequacy.
Because we went
from having comics
to be kid wish-fulfillment to
adolescent wish-fulfillment
and all that that entails.
So at the same time
this was happening,
the comic book
industry basically
decided to cut kids loose and
to focus on the teen and adult
audience.
I call it the great inward turn.
So they get it out
of the spinner racks
in grocery stores.
And we start to see the first
fan shops, the first comic book
shops where nerds can
kind of be among their own
and dissect story lines and
point out where there's been
some contradiction in canon.
And so what Denny O'Neil, who
is the writer of this reboot
of Batman, what he
decided to do was
to look back to that first year
of Batman comics for something
that he could, he could
use, he could excavate,
and find an affinity with this
new audience of older teens
and adults.
And he found that oath.
That oath went from being
a single plot point--
like this is how
you describe, this
is how you get them into the get
up-- every hero has an origin.
We just have to kind
of tick that box
to get them to put
on the bat ears.
He decided that what
Batman needed to do
was have an obsession.
OK this is the 70s.
Pop psychology is
becoming a thing.
And we need this oath to be the
thing that is all consuming.
Now he has-- when you give
him obsession like that,
you also give him a personality.
He's aloof.
He's grim.
He is increasingly gritty.
But he wasn't quite done.
Most important thing to do
after that, get rid of the kid.
So they ship Dick Grayson
off to Hudson University,
and effectively ending,
at this point, the Batman
and Robin partnership.
Which to this day, still
has these connotations.
The ghost of Fredric Wertham
hangs over these characters
whenever you see Batman
and Robin together.
And again it's not
entirely fair but it's
a thing you have to deal with.
So we can get rid of Dick
Grayson as fair as possible.
So then for the next
15 years you have,
in that upper left corner,
that's the Batman that we saw
in comics-- dark,
grim, , gritty violent.
Why is the Joker holding a fish?
Never mind, not important,
it's in the book.
You want to find out why he's
holding the fish, it's in book.
But comics at this point were
read by a few thousand people.
The Batman that the
rest of the world saw
is the one there
in the lower right,
the Super Friends
Batman, who drove around
in a car that looked
like the television show,
the '66 television show,
who called Robin "old chum",
who palled around like this.
So again, Batman alone
as a grim avenger
of the night in the comics
but that Batman in mass media,
on television, seen and
enjoyed by millions.
This is when the
difference emerges
between Batman the character,
and Batman the idea.
Nerds like me love
Batman the character.
We love all the interplay.
We love this kind of endless
iteration that goes on
and we treasure the
reboots and retcons.
And we love having these, again,
these Talmudic dissections
of what's going
on in the comics.
That's nerds.
Normals want a story,
just tell me a story.
Just give me the bullet points.
And that's the
Batman, the idea, that
continued to exist in the
public mind for 15 years
until 1985 and 1986.
This is "Batman The Dark Knight
Returns" by Frank Miller.
This book was a phenomenon
when it came out because, well,
in the book I try
to pick it apart.
He wasn't writing this
book for the nerds
he knew were Batman fans.
They were already
in the back pocket.
They were going to buy
the book regardless.
It was like this special mini
series on prestige paper.
He knew that they were
there in his back pocket.
He was writing this
book for the people
over the wall of the
little nerd enclave
that comics had built
around themselves.
He was pointing like Babe
Ruth out beyond the wall
to those people, those normals,
for whom Batman meant POW-ZAP.
If they remembered
Batman at all,
if they gave him even
a passing thought,
they thought about
two dudes fighting,
having big brawls in these
candy-colored warehouses.
POW-ZAP.
That's why you can actually read
this book "Dark Knight Returns"
as the story of what would
happen if the Adam West
Batman came back and found that
the old tropes, the old ways
of doing things,
didn't work anymore.
So you can see
when he introduces
Batman in the upper
left hand corner that
is as close as you're going
to get to the Neal Adams, yes,
but also the Adam West Batman.
Then he kind of walks
people through the history
of the character.
So we get an old costume
right there in the middle.
We also-- to take any of
that weirdness between Batman
and Robin out of it,
he makes Robin a girl.
Boom, no homoeroticism anymore,
that's all you got to do.
Gone.
And then we also have
him fight Superman
in a battle which we're still
getting elements of today--
this Friday we're going to get.
This pretty much,
this panel right here,
over and over and over again.
And he introduces this
concept of conflict.
They were pals.
They were like,
remember when-- you're
too young-- remember
when Tom and Jerry when
they were on television
in the '70s and '80s,
they became pals.
Because they didn't
want to-- the parents
groups were complaining that
there was too much violence.
So they just kind of
hung out together.
Well that's what
Superman and Batman
for most of their
history until 1985,
when Frank Miller
introduces conflict.
So one of the things that I
talk about in the book a lot
is that a character like Batman
is a comic book character.
Comic books are basically soap
operas-- narrative-- endless,
iterating narrative
without an ending.
These characters are
heavily licensed nuggets
of intellectual
property who are not
supposed to grow and change.
They're not supposed to do
what fiction characters,
fictional characters do.
What makes a story a story
is you have an ending.
And the person is a different
person at the end of the story
than they are at the beginning.
Can't happen with
Batman unless you do
some kind of Elseworld stuff.
What Frank Miller
did was, he knew
that if I give this-- if we look
at this character at the end
of his career, all of
a sudden the stakes
are rising because his physical
prowess isn't where it was,
where he's at the
height of his career
and also at the
beginning of his career.
So that's what "Batman
Year One", which
he wrote the next year, does.
It basically says,
here's how he came to be.
But he doesn't go
through the origin again.
We get a glimpse of the guns
and the pearls and everything.
But he mostly-- it's
a process piece,
especially how do
I go from a guy who
I know what I want to do.
How do I get to that
guy right there?
Now when you take a
character like Batman
out of the comic book
page and you put him
into any other medium,
you change him--
for the better, for the worse,
sometimes doesn't matter.
We'll see.
But what you're doing
is you are overlaying
your own stuff,
your own baggage,
on top of the character.
Tim Burton's kind of
outsider, emo weirdness
on top of the character--
Joel Schumacher
is whatever the hell that
was on top of the character.
Christopher Nolan's concerns
with the surveillance state
and terrorism and it doesn't
really hang together.
But never mind, it's important.
He's kind of drafting
on big ideas.
And then you got Ben
Affleck up there.
That is just the
funniest-- doesn't it
look like he just is like
he's taking a class picture
and he doesn't want to be there?
Just like he's a sullen emo kid
which, the story checks out.
So again, to adapt
this character
is to change the character.
And in the very first
1989 Batman film, who
killed Bruce Wayne's parents?
The Joker, because that
is the action movie trope.
That is-- when you
put a character that
doesn't end into
an action movie,
you give him the
three act structure.
You give him the love interest.
You give him the rising action.
You give him the big
reveal, that the thing that
happened in the first reel
is solved by the thing that
happens in the end.
It turns Batman into
Charles Bronson when
you have this revenge story.
And the thing about
superheroes is that they're not
action movie heroes.
They do not kill.
They have restraint.
It would be the easiest
thing in the world
to have Batman just go in with
an Oozie and blow things down.
But he's not Rambo.
He has restraint.
He has a genre conventions.
With in genre conventions
you have creativity.
If you do away with
genre conventions,
you're not writing
a Batman story.
Now people ask me
which of these,
or the one in the books,
which is my Batman?
The whole point of
the book is that there
is many different Batman,
many different Batman exist.
We project onto this
character which one we want.
My Batman is not the Adam
West one, although I love him.
My Batman is the one
that I think nailed it.
We have taken this character
out of the comic book medium
many times.
Only once did we nail it.
And that is "Batman the Animated
Series" in the early 90s.
Again, all those
other forms of media
put the directors, the
writers, the screenplays,
the studios baggage on
top of the character.
This series stripped
everything else away,
leaving us with
as close a view as
were ever going to
get of who Batman is
and why he does what he does.
It's also just in terms
of design, it's amazing.
You're basically
taking the comic book
and giving it fluidity
and movement and strength.
And also-- and I
don't think this
is a coincidence-- the
half hour syndicated
format of the animated
series is as close as we
can get to the comic book
format where things don't really
change at the end.
Where he's still the same dude,
but over the course of time,
over the course of
several seasons,
we can allow a little bit
more breathing room in there.
We can actually
make a character.
We can give-- we can have some
funnier episodes, some darker
episodes.
We can allow these relationships
between these characters
to deepen and to actually
allow for his characterization.
So I'm going to close
with a very short story.
Which is that I was
at Comic-Con in 2013
doing some research for the
book interviewing people.
And it was the last day
of the convention floor.
And it was 2013, there were
Batman all over the damn place.
They were all the
Christopher Nolan Batman.
And you can spot them.
Now if you've never
been to Comic-Con,
it's just this giant floor
bursting with color and lights
and sounds.
And you could see the
Christopher Nolan Batman
from a mile away because they
were just absorbing light.
They were like these
little black worker ants.
They were kind of
milling about the floor.
They were all pissed.
They were all
doing very method--
I smiled at one when he passed
me and he kind of growls.
I was like, good for you.
Well done.
And then I turned and I saw
Batman, the Adam West Batman.
And it was perfect.
Every detail of that
costume was spot on,
the wrinkles of the evening
gloves, the tininess
of the insignia-- which makes
it seem more polite somehow,
like he doesn't want to make
a big thing-- the bulkiness
of the utility
belt, and the cowl
which have these
weird like drag queen
eyebrows drawn on it
for no reason, none.
And I was like, dude,
that is, that is perfect.
Do you have any idea
how perfect that is?
And he said to me, do
you want a picture?
And I said, well I hadn't
but now all of a sudden,
I very much did.
So I was like, yes, definitely.
So I didn't take pictures of
people there because I just
didn't.
So he backs up into the
aisle and I'm like, OK.
And he says, do you
want me to pose?
And again, I hadn't, but
now, sure, do it-- go nuts.
Isn't that perfect?
Look at that guy.
So that's-- he's
doing the Batusi--
what I want to point
out here is the paunch.
The paunch is perfect.
Right next to him--
you can't see it--
but there was a
300 soldier dude--
you know the Frank
Miller 300 soldier
guy-- who was just jacked
and had 0% body fat.
And you could tell that this
guy just ate chicken breasts
and guzzled Muscle Milk.
So I figured that there must
be some kind of training
procedure for that paunch.
That must be like pasta
buffets and Schlitz.
I think it's the way you get
to that thing right there.
And again, I should
point out as well
that it's not fair to Adam
West to a kind of concentrate
on the paunch because
Adam West was trim.
His stunt double had
a bit of a thing.
So every time you
see them fighting,
you get a little
bit of a wiggle.
But that was the end of
my Comic-Con experience.
All right, thank you very much.
Let's do some questions.
If anybody has any questions
about any aspect of the stuff
I kind of breezed
through right then.
AUDIENCE: First, thanks to
you so much for coming here
to speak with us.
I wish I could ask you
this after the review
embargo for Batman versus
Superman was lifted,
but I'll just try it anyway.
How do you feel
about the direction
the DC cinematic universe is
taking Batman with the newest
movie?
GLEN WELDON: Yeah, I haven't
seen it so I can talk.
Because actually
the press screening
is actually tomorrow night when
I'm having the book launch.
So I feel, I think
that's the universe
kind of cutting me a break.
They learned the wrong
lesson from Green Lantern,
which Green Lantern sucked.
But it didn't suck
because there were jokes.
It didn't suck
because they tried
to inject some humor into it.
It sucked for a whole
host of reasons.
And to go-- to try to
fit the Christopher Nolan
model, the tone, onto
a character like Batman
makes in certain amount of
sense-- grim, dour, gritty,
story checks out.
To try to fit in on the
Man of Steel, on Superman,
is just a fundamental misread
of who this character is.
They are not the same.
They work in the same universe.
But you have to deal with
him in very different tones.
So you know what, I said on
the Pop Culture Happy Hour
that I believe that
this film could be good.
The more I read about
it, the more I see it,
I really-- I live in a
tortured kind of hope.
But just this
morning Ben Affleck
said, yeah, I don't think I'm
going to take my kid to see it.
So the story about the detective
ninja and the flying guy
it's not for kids.
None of this stuff is for kids.
That doesn't make
any sense to me.
AUDIENCE: Would
you say it's kind
of going through its own
inward turn, or sorry--
GLEN WELDON: Oh, sure.
Yeah, as a matter of fact.
I think-- I don't know
how old Zack Snyder is,
but something happened
in the '90s to comics
where they became more
extreme and violent.
And it was all splash pages,
spectacle over storytelling.
But there's an old saw that the
comics you loved when you're 13
are the comics that you will
always love, whatever they are.
And I have a feeling Zack
Snyder read a lot of 90s comics
because this movie looks like
an Image comic brought to life.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GLEN WELDON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It was
interesting what you just
said about the '90s and the
sort of extreme era of comics.
It seems that with
Batman he's often
tonally based by the authors
who are handling him.
You said this is true
of the movies as well.
And I also noticed it's
sort of a repetitive cycle
that when he gets too dark, is
when they reintroduce a Robin.
Do you think it could be
possible for a film Robin
to come and maybe clean up
the darkness of film Batman?
GLEN WELDON: When you get a
Robin introduced in the films
previously, it's by
Joel Schumacher who
brought in a Robin who
was given to tank tops
and he had an earring and he
was basically rough trade Robin.
And that's not necessarily the
way you lighten the film mood.
That's not the way you
necessarily turn the cycle.
He goes through this and
he's done it several times
over the years where he
is the lone vigilante,
then he is the father
figure to Robin.
Then he is the leader
of this giant brood.
And then again, as
you say, they ditch.
Over and over again
they ditch the kid,
they ditch the brood to get
him back to grim and gritty.
You can see in-- there's
a series in the mid-aughts
into the tens, called "Batman,
the Brave and the Bold"
which was an animated
series that injected
a little bit of humor.
You can see now merch from
the 1966 television series
after a period of time
when DC Comics wanted
to pretend like
that never existed
because they wanted grim.
They wanted gritty.
They wanted that
version of Batman
to be the only
version of Batman.
Now it wasn't necessarily
because they were afraid of it.
There's all kinds
of rights issues
with getting any kind of
imagery from that series.
Because if you
remember, every episode
had a guest star,
a guest villain,
and so they had to get the
rights from the guest villain
and then work with
their estates.
And so it just took years.
But now if you
look around you can
see some light being injected
back into the whole universe.
So now as I say the
way it should be
is that there's a
Batman for everybody.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when it comes
to the Christopher Nolan
trilogy, what is
your biggest concern
with the whole
surveillance state story?
And also-- it's a
two-part question--
from Adam West to
Ben Affleck who
do you think-- which
Batman had the best chin?
GLEN WELDON: Ah, see-- there
is a chapter on the chin.
It actually keeps coming back.
I kept reading all these
reviews of these films
as they were coming out.
And at one point
Roger Ebert says,
I think Clooney
has the best chin.
It's a thing.
Because it's the
only thing you see
of the character, of the actor.
It's the only thing you see.
In the era of Kevlar
suits, you know,
what the guy's chin-- whether
or not there's a dimple matters.
Usually because Bob Kane used
to draw him as like-- basically
Dick Tracy-- square jawed.
And it's hugely important to
the character in a weird way
that nerds hold onto.
I say in the book
that Batman speaks
to the ideal of masculinity
of every 12-year-old kid who's
had his lunch money
stolen one too many times.
Bruce Wayne appeals to the
desire to look great in a tux.
So you need both.
As for the surveillance state,
I thought that was interesting.
I just didn't think
it hung together.
It makes sense.
I mean, Batman--
in the comics there
have been all these stories
about Batman making contingency
plans, contingency plans,
planning everything out,
observing everybody,
spying on everybody.
It makes sense
that this character
who is paranoid and obsessed
would go down that road.
It felt, as I said,
like no one was
sort of drafting
off of a big idea
and not necessarily
engaging with it.
I don't think there's
a consistent viewpoint
about the surveillance
state that you
can define from that film.
I don't think there's
a consistent viewpoint
about terrorism that you
can define from that film.
It's-- he came to these
big ideas and he said,
let's do something with it.
And he did something
with it but it's not
like it's necessarily
a through line.
Yes, who's next?
AUDIENCE: So you
spoke in the beginning
about there being a lot
of killing in the comics.
And then they did away
with that for the children.
And then more recently there's
the principle, never kill.
Could you speak a bit about
the arc about Batman killing
versus not killing.
GLEN WELDON: Sure.
Yeah, it's been a
part of the character
since about-- since
after his first year.
When he mowed people down
with that machine gun,
they said, no, let's
make sure he never kills.
And then when
creators of the comic
want to do something splashy
and make a big impact
they show him on the
cover with a gun.
The restraint
against firearms is
a part of the character, which
is why when I see in the 1989
Batman film the guns
on the Batmobile,
when I play Batman
Arkham City and there's
guns-- rubber
bullets of course--
but still, there's
guns on the Batmobile,
like that's a cop
out-- rubber bullets.
It's something that I think is
hugely important because we're
not making a story about
an action movie hero.
When action movie
heroes kill a villain,
we get this cathartic, yeah!
That's a big part of the
action movie experience.
So we don't mind that Charles
Bronson wipes people out.
We don't mind that Clint
Eastwood wipes people out.
This guy is dedicated
to preserving life
and for him to kill is
a fundamental undoing
of his mission statement.
He is trying to keep that
trauma or anybody else
from suffering the trauma
that he suffered as a kid.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming, by the way, really
appreciate it.
And in the spirit
of nerding out,
I have a good question
for you that I
think is one that's
gone on multiple times
and many people have asked
over the course of time.
I'm curious what
your opinion is.
What is your thought in
regards to who is the mask,
or is it a mask within a mask?
Is Bruce Wayne the mask?
Is Batman the mask?
Is it actually a
mask within a mask.
And really in his
inner child he's
this little fluffy marshmallow
of emotion wanting to be happy.
So what is your thought on that?
GLEN WELDON: I was just talking
to [? Sara Beth ?] about this.
There is an episode of the
animated series where Batman
has some kind of-- no,
it's "Batman Beyond"
where Batman is having
some kind of mental trauma.
And the way he figures out
that he was not going insane
and that it was
all an illusion was
because in one of the
versions Batman basically
calls him Bruce.
And he says, in my head I
don't call myself Bruce.
I think anybody who
plays the character is
playing three versions of him.
He's playing the Griff,
swear to me, Batman.
He's playing this kind of
socialite, smarmy jerk.
And he's playing the
survivor of the trauma
that he suffered as a
youth, that Bruce Wayne.
And I think that Bruce Wayne
is as close as you get.
But I do think Batman is
his reaction to this thing.
So his true self,
I think, is Batman.
That's my take.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
I have a completely
unrelated question,
if everyone's okay with that.
I'm curious-- you
didn't touch on--
as we went back to the
death of Jason Todd,
for example, that was
an impactful thing.
That was an interesting thing
that was kind of driven by,
I don't know if I want
to say commercialism.
But they let people have
a poll to actually make
a decision on it that
was shockingly close.
And so I'm curious,
does that play
into what you think of the
development of the character
and also the development of
the character in the space
of the commercial world?
GLEN WELDON: Yes.
Again, they periodically
throw the kid under the rug--
literally, six feet under
the rug to get him back
to basics, to restart.
In the case of Jason Todd
they couldn't figure out
how to write him.
He was an insolent punk
and I voted to kill him.
I was one of the
thousands of people
who voted to off the little
kid because he was surly.
He was a jerk.
And, yeah, it was a huge event.
None of them who did that
event-- they ran a poll,
should we killed Jason Todd
or should we let him live?
And people voted.
The margin was only
about 8000 or so people
voters or something like that,
but the margin was 72 votes.
One of mine was--
put it over the top.
And yes, they didn't expect
it to become the big to-do
that it did.
They were-- because everybody
within the-- it's kind
of like what happened
when they killed Superman.
Everybody in the industry knew
that it was a marketing stunt
but Newsweek didn't and
The New York Times didn't.
They thought this was actually
a permanent change because they
don't know how
superhero comics work,
where everything comes back.
And Jason Todd has come back.
And it's because, again, we
have to keep this story going
and that means things
like logical sense
go out the wayside.
And we just churn.
It's a constant
churn of character
and ideas and narrative.
And yeah-- it's-- I
would kill him again.
AUDIENCE: Thumbs up to that.
GLEN WELDON: All right,
I think that's it.
I want to thank you guys
for having me very much.
I enjoyed it.
And if you want to
talk to me afterwards,
I'll be over there signing
books and thanks again.